learners permit thursdays on my youtube
subscribe today the night pants nation
tour is underway cleveland you are up
next december 9th through the 11th la
jolla you're right after that december
17th through the 19th and austin we're
kicking off 2022 down there january 6th
through the 8th get your tickets now at
ryansickler.com
hey guys ryan sickler here and i just
want to let you know that ringtones of
my laugh are now available for android i
don't know why you'd want it i can't
it's beyond me i do love it though i
love hearing that you guys are scaring
your kids and your animals with my
ringtones uh we listened heard you
responded ringtones of my laugh are
available for android and apple all
right you get them everywhere you get
ringtones you can go to ryansickler.com
and download the ringtones for android
directly
[Music]
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media thank you again for your
support on the night pants nation tour
we're rolling right along la jolla
december 15th through the 17th austin
texas uh january 6 through the 8th
i can't thank you enough for your
support on this show it continues to
grow and grow we've talked about a lot
of serious [ __ ]
um so please subscribe to the youtube
and uh if you have a story or you know
someone has a story that has to be heard
please submit it for the patreon show
the honeydew with you all submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com
if you haven't subscribed yet i promise
you you're missing out i say it every
week we're solving cold cases people are
getting [ __ ] ripped out of them
people are living in the wilderness
surviving in the wilderness overnight
people are getting brains blown on them
where else are you getting that in
comedy it's five bucks a month if you
sign up for a year you get over a month
free and you get the honeydew a day
early ad-free at no additional cost all
right let's go all the information you
needs at ryansickler.com
and uh that's the biz all right you know
what we do here we highlight the low
lights and we try to bring some light
into that darkness and uh today
no uh no exception this is gonna be a
different one for us um but i would love
to welcome back to the honeydew y'all
please welcome back hannah dickinson
everybody welcome back to the honey yeah
uh
a year later you know and just is it
about a year now yeah it keeps getting
worse huh
all right we thought herpes was bad
i love the people who haven't seen your
episode yet they're like did she just
say herpes yeah i have herpes so i don't
know we're gonna get into all that
uh but please promote plug everything
you would like i have a podcast called
don't tell mom where
i just talk about things that my mom
gets upset about uh which
and we talk about like
bad moms which i don't know if that's
mean but
well i'm really selling my podcast huh i
i have nothing to promote
what about social media oh i'm at hans
dickey your [ __ ] videos are the [ __ ]
though i told you
look i'm such a fan i know we first met
last year you did your epic special
which you have if you haven't seen our
epic stand-up special you should
definitely watch it
and um
i don't know we clicked off of that and
i really just took to you and your story
and you came here very bravely sharing
this vulnerable story about living with
your parents during the pandemic being
lonely you meet a guy who has genital
herpes and does not tell you and gives
it to you and then you come here and
share it with the world
and i told you the two funniest [ __ ]
lines i've heard
last year were
general herpes is like a dui for the
[ __ ] it really is
and we did a show together the other day
at the comedy store i didn't even know
you were on it i saw your day i was like
[ __ ] yeah i can't wait and you added the
line
uh it doesn't it doesn't stop you but it
slows you down yeah
and then the other one was i caught the
wrong virus
everybody else is getting corroded
yeah ventilators are looking pretty good
right now
i shouldn't say that probably huh
and you come out and you tell us about
it and you also make it so funny
and just i thought it was a great
episode because so many people
deal with it and you know you were you
told me you were freaked out about it
affecting you moving forward and now
you're like oh
everybody's a [ __ ] got it
yeah i haven't i have to say i've gotten
a lot of dms from doing your podcast
that's probably a lot of people like i
have it too so you want to hook up are
you getting those
um not really your fans are respectful
which is i love here yeah it's nice um
they're always like
probably you know just very unlike some
guys are like open your legs you know
never from the honeydew i love that good
and uh but yeah i have to say a year and
a half later it's like you can only it
only affects you if you're having an
outbreak and i haven't had one at all no
good so
it's i do regret telling the world for
sure
like i should have kept this to my
[ __ ] self
and i found out
i was like why did i tell everyone oh
and then if i start dating a guy and
he's like oh you do comedy i'm like
don't google me like don't please don't
watch it
because it's the first thing that comes
up and i'm like
he's like i googled you i'm like okay
goodbye nice to meet you
uh but yeah and then i found out like i
won't say names but a big comedian has
it and they don't they don't tell i
won't say what their gender is but i'm
like they're [ __ ] smart they're out
here
talking about
having sex
i'm telling the wrong stories you're not
you're being real true sure and it
hasn't really affected me anyway well
today
and unfortunately we're going to talk
about some real [ __ ] some very ugly [ __ ]
i see you at the comedy store
and i haven't seen you since the show
since we did the actual episode together
because you're in new york i'm here in
l.a
and i was so stoked to see you and i ran
right up and i gave you the biggest hug
and then
what did you say to me since the last
time i saw you i went to rehab oh yeah i
said i know i sent you a little message
but i didn't want to pry and ask why or
what was going on and then you told me
the reason you went to rehab and i
just yeah
yeah i
do i guess i just say it i was uh
last time i was in la
i was
this was about yeah six months ago
i was drinking the night before my
birthday
and i got into an uber with my friend or
what we thought was our uber he drops my
friend off and he takes off and rapes me
and then
brings me back to his house
and
i wake up the next morning in his bed
this is what you're telling me before
i'm about to go up and down
i'm like i gotta go i gotta go on stage
yeah i was like yeah it was really scary
anyway um do you have any water or gum
or anything
speaking of uber did you go
oh my god
yeah i mean that's what you said to me
because that's what [ __ ] happened to
you and i was like wait and listen i
told you i have a story
that i've started telling
recently on tour
about being in an uber with my friend
and i thought this guy was gonna kill us
so i i bring up
and again never i'm a guy i'm not
worried about rape i'm not worried about
somebody raping me when i get in a car
or
trying to [ __ ] me up when i pass them on
the street my my friends who are women
are like yeah i worry about every guy
that walks past me on the sidewalk
because i know that guy could probably
take me and
so
i just said out loud to the audience i
genuinely ask how many people been in a
ride share uber lift whatever and
generally thought this person's gonna
kill me and i thought three or four
people would clap at night and it's
half the audience or more every [ __ ]
night so there's obviously
it's a problem with [ __ ] going on out
there so
can you take us back to the night and
how it all happens because you said a
key thing you also said that said what
we thought was our uber yeah
so
yeah i guess
it what's crazy is like
i was going through a really hard time
during that period like uh
two days before
like i was in a weird rel i got into a
relationship that moved way too quickly
he started yelling at me all the time
and then he was supposed to go on this
trip with me
my boyfriend
and um he broke up with me like the
night before um
i was going to new york to fly out with
him
so i ended up going to new york by
myself and getting a hotel room because
i'm like flying out to la from there
and i take a bunch of mushrooms by
yourself i'm by myself
in like midtown
and i have like a really bad trip and i
call my dad and i was like i need to go
to rehab i'm in trouble and then my dad
was like you you know he didn't to be
fair it
he didn't realize like everything i was
going through i didn't disclose that he
thinks it's just this moment you're
having now he was like you just got
dumped you need to go be with your
friends from college like you need to
just relax and he was right i did need
to relax but like i couldn't relax
and then i went to i came to l.a went to
dinner with my friend i was like i feel
like i'm gonna die and she was like what
does that even mean i was like i don't
know i just have this dark cloud it felt
like
i felt like
i was cursed or something it was just a
weird like i couldn't
i don't know and she was like you're
taking too many mushrooms that's what
she said and she was right
uh
and then the next she was like call your
therapist so the next day i was like the
day before my birthday
i had an emergency made with my
therapist i was like i don't know what's
going on like i feel off like i feel
like something's gonna happen and she's
like just chill just like relax
and that what are you thinking do you
thought death yeah you did i was like my
death
like finality why because
i had this
anxiety that was like
if you don't change something you're
going to die like the path you're going
on you're going to die and i had been
drinking a lot
i got into this really
abusive relationship that i was like
kind of letting happen like he would
like yell at me and i would make about
what just anything
like he yelled at me because i
scratched his leather couch
with my backpack
he yelled at me because i'm sorry yes
no it's [ __ ] like that's crazy i didn't
close the shower curtain after i used it
so i kept it open and he said that's how
you get mildew so he yelled at me for
that
i asked him yelled not not told you're
what i [ __ ] sag you know just like
[ __ ] like that and i was letting it
happen
and so i was treating myself like [ __ ]
and so i think it was just like well
said by the way i was tr even though he
is also i was treating myself like [ __ ]
that's important too yeah because
ultimately i should have just packed my
[ __ ] up and been like [ __ ] you and
walked out the first time he yelled at
me but i was like making excuses for him
which is only hurting myself
and it's really hard to do in the moment
and like i have friends yeah we've all
done that exactly and then i just
watched the brittany murphy documentary
have you seen that oh my you have to see
that
i like her she was always one of my
faves super cute loved her and eight
mile loved her and what was the crit the
one with angelina jolie the oh girl
interrupted yeah i [ __ ] loved her
yeah she was so talented but she got in
this horrible abusive controlling
relationship and i'm not comparing to
brittany murphy but it also didn't get
that far so it's like they start small
and then
but anyway he broke up with me so
i'm like i didn't let it get that far i
didn't let it get that far
he told me to not come over so
too much mildew on the shower
yeah he was like
yeah it was
i asked if i could borrow gum once or i
said can i have a piece of this gum he's
like i told you not to ask me questions
just
use this apartment like it's your own
and i was like well i have been doing
that new year's angriest friendliest
thing though yeah
wait you're mad at me for asking
anyway so i just and then i get to the
la and i go to the pool with my friend
before dinner and this guy comes up to
me and he's like can i put my dick
inside of you whoa he walked up and said
that
yes
he's like
and people at the pool because we were
at this pool in santa monica um at this
hotel in santa monica it was a really
nice hotel that was my birthday gift as
my parents got me a nice hotel in santa
monica
and this guy is so wasted and he's like
you got that good [ __ ]
and i go
actually i do not
i have genital herpes
and
my friend is like she looks at me like
are you you're gonna engage with this
guy
and give him that yes
he's like oh is that the one with the
bumps and i was
like oh you're not you're conversating
about it and i'm like yep that's the one
with the bumps and he's like you taking
that medication i was like i am and he's
like don't take the medication you got
to open your [ __ ] up to the sun and and
like let the sun raise like cure your
[ __ ] and i was like i'll think about
that
next time
well he keeps harassing me and i was
like we have boyfriends like you need to
leave
and you think it's a crowded pool you
think someone would comment no they're
filming it people are filming it my
friend was like hannah we're going to
end up on [ __ ]
that's what happens today yeah and the
thing is they probably would have caught
it to just me being like i have genital
herpes you know not like
i mean i guess they could find that yeah
which could be found anywhere obviously
at this point
me saying that but um
yeah so it was like that day that
happened and also
uh a week before i was at a hotel in st
louis because we were shooting stuff
with nikki glazer so that's why i was
there for work and the guy bringing my
towels i offered i went and get i said
oh i'm so sorry i don't have cash but
i'll come and give you cash and i went
and got cash and gave it to him because
i hate when people say like
so i went and made sure went out of my
way i get home that night he slips a
note under my door
that says um i think i have it i put on
twitter and it was like you're the most
beautiful girl i've ever seen i would
like to come over this morning and eat
your [ __ ] that i i swear to god why
can't guys stop it you're the most
beautiful girl i've ever seen and i'm
like you know
i love it to an extent like when i put
on twitter people like not gonna lie he
had me in the first half and i was like
i agree like it started strong it ended
with this smiley face with the tongue
i swear to god he threw a handwritten
emoji i wanted for you
so that happened
and i just felt like so that happened
the week before so then your pussy's
radiating something to have men come up
to you like that and do that kind of
[ __ ] i know i was like i don't even have
crystals like this [ __ ] i need to get
crystals it was just like i felt like
aggressive harassment so it felt like i
didn't feel safe anywhere
and then um this is all in that leading
up to that yeah a week before
and then you get this guy at the pool
and then the next night
i my friend has a date and i was like
i'm just gonna stay in and then i like
couldn't be by myself i just couldn't
like i couldn't be alone
and my guy friend i met him because he
lived right around the corner so we i
met him and we were someone you've known
yeah i've known him for like six years
and um
so we went and got a drink and to be
fair i at the time wasn't eating at all
so like
yeah i just like wasn't really eating
and i was drinking a lot so like my
calories were like
magic mushrooms and wine and like that's
what my what's in my system okay and um
and valtrex of course
um
it'll happen
i know but you know it's my it's my
that's what i'm famous for on here so um
gotta stick to the hits
let's stick to that
so then we get to the last thing i
remember is us getting i
so we're at drinking and then the waiter
but he's like oh it's your birthday
tomorrow i'll get you shots and like
i've been like on and off sober for a
while and i was like if i ever start
doing shots again that's when i'll get
sober that never works it never works to
be like i'm not gonna take shots or i'm
not gonna do it just always end up
spiraling
what is it that you like about drinking
i actually learned this in rehab about
myself they've read my brain waves and i
run on such high anxiety and my brain is
always just like
pushing itself and not even in the best
way just like always like
always just
worst case scenario just so
i'm just such an anxious person that
like he said it makes sense you're a
binge drinker because alcohol slows you
down and relaxes you so your brain is
like this is good this is good and it
can't stop so i have no stop okay and
that's my issue it's just you do feel
more comfortable and
relaxed when you drink
for the first three
and then it's like
i mean
how many would you say you have
back then a night or is it just bit you
say binge so are you friday saturday
yeah then nothing for three days exactly
okay it's like or sometimes i could have
a glass of wine but like if i have a
glass of wine i'd be like
why'd i do that
you know like it doesn't make sense to
me to have one glass of wine because why
five is better it's just like yeah if
i'm going to be drinking let's be drink
it's so stupid no it's i just want to
understand the
totality behind it so if you're going
for it then go for it yeah and sometimes
i'll i mean i could just have a glass of
wine but i usually like
it's usually once i hit three like i'm
like what's a four like it's like in my
brain cannot stop me
and i can't be like and i've tried for
[ __ ] years like i'm i started going
to a when i was 23. like i've tried so
many times to be like
stop stop at four does it run in your
family
actually my parents and i just had this
conversation because
i asked what age as a kid was i the
hardest to deal with like thinking they
would say three to six my dad was like i
would say it started at 21.
started he said
he didn't say just the age of 21. yes my
trump when i was the
toughest and that was when i turned 21.
i mean
yeah
so
my parent i don't know my mom is you
know came it was irish catholic family
so like i feel my mom's not alcoholic
but
i think her grandparents might have been
or her
not her parents but and my dad's
sister is a really bad she's sober now
but
so i think it's just kind of
luck of the draw but it's in the family
okay
and so that night i'm sorry i wanted to
know what it was about alcohol so that
night oh yeah so that night i remember
the last thing i remember was taking a
shot and actually the guy who i was with
we dated at one point we went on like
two or three dates but we were so he we
would just get so drunk that he was like
we're the worst combination of people
and i was like yeah let's just be
friends uh
but now we are friends but um
he's when he said that five years ago
he's absolutely correct because the next
you know i go out with him six years
later and this happens and it's not his
fault by any means and like he's equally
a victim as myself but it sucks because
i'm the girl so like do you think at
that point you were slipped anything
is there anything in that shot or in the
drinks that you're having do you think
and i don't even mean your friend i mean
i remember it was a few years ago it was
in santa monica and they were [ __ ] they
caught a guy and they were watching them
just dropped drinks these bartenders and
[ __ ] you know so do you think that you
had more than you normally have and you
got [ __ ] up or is there a chance that
something was in your system
it is possible sometimes in my system
because i but i didn't drink that much
like i probably had two glasses of wine
a margarita and a shot which isn't a lot
but
okay um and over like maybe two and a
half glasses
but not like not a i'm like maybe maybe
four bottles uh no bottles
but i did i remember being like oh i
should probably eat more if i'm gonna
drink and i didn't
um
so you've got the magic mushrooms and
wine from earlier and you just continue
with liquid diet the rest of the night
there's no food you didn't eat anything
no okay so and you have what you just
told us you have yeah and then i
remember leaving the restaurant
and seeing this bush in santa monica you
know and third we're at 1212 santa
monica
whatever and those like bushes shaped
like dinosaurs
and i remember being like that's weird
and then getting i remem vaguely
remember getting into the opening the
car and being like can we take my friend
home i can add it like i don't remember
like exactly what i said but he i
remember him being like because my
friend was like oh i'm gonna go to
7-eleven right there and the guy was
like oh don't add it in
i'll just take him okay
so he drops my friend off at 7 11
and
i vaguely remember my friend being like
text me when you're home
and that's i don't remember anything
else
and i woke up the next day and i was
looking at a wall
which i my hotel had like a king bed in
the middle of a room so it wouldn't have
been next to a wall
and i was like holy [ __ ] and i was like
that's so weird
and
i i wake up to like a guy putting a
blanket on me because i i was like i was
like kind of shivering i had
i had my top on from the night before
and my pants were on my ankles
but like that's how you woke up yeah
and i was sorry if this is too graphic i
was on my period so there was blood
everywhere
like everywhere i was on the first day
of the second day of my period
so
i woke up to a guy putting like a
blanket over me and i and i was like
what the [ __ ] so i look over and i
immediately recognize him as my uber
driver and i sit up and i'm like
oh my oh my [ __ ] god like i i was
like about to have a panic i like
immediately knew what happened but my
body was in shock like it was like
i couldn't piece everything together but
i knew we didn't go anywhere else like i
remember seeing getting in this guy's
car
and
i
also knew i was on my period like i was
just like
you know
someone would argue like maybe you
flirted with him whatever this kid was
maybe 18 years old he was like 17 or 18
years old you woke up in this guy's
kid's house yes
and so i'm like i like start i start
like i'm having a pants so this lunatic
covering you up yes how many he
based on the records which i can get
into later based on our
my uber because i tried calling an uber
where he raped me because he raped me in
a parking lot and then in the car yes
and then drove me back to his family
home dragged my lifeless body
probably with my pants and my ankles
into the house
and put me in bed and then the next
morning is like oh this person that i
raped in the back of my car looks cold
let me sh let me just put this blanket
over her like jesus the the separation
of crate like how psychologically [ __ ]
up
you have to be to be like
oh this poor person like i should care
for her almost as if that guy's not the
one that did that to you exactly
and i woke up and i started so then i'm
hyperventilating and i'm like oh my god
oh my god oh my god
and he's like oh don't worry about my
sheets
because there's blood everywhere he
thinks i'm i'm worried about his [ __ ]
right i'm like oh are they frate like
are you kidding me
you think i'm worried about your [ __ ]
sheets right now
i was like your rooms have disaster how
are you not grounded
i was like
i'm furious
you're like i'm worried about your
[ __ ] sheets
i was like
i was like did you have sex with me
he goes yeah we had sex last night i go
we did not have sex i said you raped me
and he goes he that was the look in his
face like oh [ __ ] like he was like have
you seen promising young woman no
it's a really good movie it's on hbo max
but it's kind of about that how guys
will be like
oh it's
consensual and then when she would be
like i'm actually not drunk what the
[ __ ] are you doing they'd be like
like that's what the whole movie's about
is baiting guys into thinking they're
taking home a drunk girl
and the look in every guy's eye in that
movie was the look in his eye like
[ __ ]
and he was like you have to keep your
voice down my parents are so right away
he knows he's busted and now he's
begging you not to he's begging me not
to tell his mommy that he raped me are
they in the house yeah he's like there
are children in the house you have to be
children are at home with he's a he
brought you to his parents house yes
literally i was like
what kind of house are you in do you
know where the [ __ ] you're here in
california where the [ __ ] are you i'm in
compton in a house in compton no yeah
so i i don't know what this at this
point and i so he's like keep your voice
out and i at this point i'm kind of
scared because i'm like what if he has a
weapon yeah and so i check i'm also
wearing which is crazy to me a lot of
jewelry that's expensive i have a
designer purse
and he doesn't that's i told my friend i
was like he didn't even steal anything
she's like
that's a different thing to guys and i'm
like that's so
i'm like you didn't even take my bag
that's so weird
plenty of opportunities missed
opportunities here
just so [ __ ] up
but that that also strikes me as like oh
just because you're a rapist doesn't
mean you're a thief like and that's
it's not a universal you're
just because you rape doesn't mean
you're gonna kill steal
yeah and that's why i feel so lucky is
like yes i was raped but like i have all
my i had all my things um
but anyway so
in the moment so i grab i'm looking
around making sure i have all my jewelry
i'm making sure i have my i'm like
trying to do it fast but am i screaming
are you i'm at this point i'm not
screaming anymore because he was like
keep your voice down and i was like what
if he has a gun like i don't know where
i am at this point big was he a big dude
no
he was like 18 like i i hope
i'm like am i going to go to jail for
this like this is so young
i was like am i crystal i'm sorry wait
should we have to cut that
i'm like [ __ ]
i'm like this guy is so
young like in his his like posters and
you know and but i don't know where i am
at this point and again i'm still
processing what has just happened yes
honestly i'm insecure about my skin i
mean i'm insecure about the way i look
for obvious reasons but you know bags
under my eyes acne i thought acne i
seriously thought acne would stop it
like your 20s you know what i mean i
can't believe
i'm in my 40s and i'm still getting
pimples all right so
there's nothing wrong with taking care
of your skin and people who think
skincare is exclusively for women i'm
telling y'all you're dead wrong dudes
disco is a clean skincare brand based in
austin texas all disco products are
created specifically for male skin
issues like under eye bags dark circles
acne razor burn oily skin dry skin and
wrinkles disco products are easy to use
they're effective and they're affordable
they take the guesswork out of taking
care of your skin their disco repairing
eye stick is formulated with caffeine
peptides and moisturizer to transform
those under eye bags after a long night
of partying gaming working or whatever
your vice may be if you want to check
out disco and try their incredible skin
care products for yourself we have a
special offer for our honeydew audience
go to letsdisco.com
honeydew or enter honeydew at checkout
for 30 off your first order that's
letsdisco.com honeydew for 30 off your
first order thank you disco this holiday
season everly well can help you give
more by gifting an everly well at-home
lab test you're giving your loved ones
more comfort clarity self-discovery and
joy and well-being everly well offers
affordable at-home lab tests that give
you trusted physician-reviewed results
choose from tests including food
sensitivity metabolism sleep and stress
thyroid and so much more here's how it
works every well ships your test
straight to your door with everything
needed for a simple sample collection
return the test to a clia certified lab
with a prepaid shipping label and then
your physician reviewed results and
insights are sent to your device in just
days over a million people have trusted
everly well with their at-home lab
testing i personally did it exactly what
they said happens it comes right to your
door you take it i did the food
sensitivity test boom a quick finger
prick a little drop of blood off it goes
and uh
i don't know it was like a few days i
got my test results back and apparently
i'm sensitive to ginger that's what i
found out other than that i'm good to go
this holiday give more of what matters
with an everly well at-home lab test for
our listeners everly wells offering a
special discount of 20 off and at home
lab tests at everlyweld.com
honeydew that's
everlywell.com honeydew for 20 off your
at-home lab test everlywell.com
honeydew there is nothing better than
watching your child's imagination in
action as they unlock new ways of seeing
the world little passports offers
award-winning play-based kits that fuel
curiosity through fun hands-on
activities they'll love the feeling of
discovery almost as much as you'll love
watching them explore we got some my
daughter and i stella sat down
we went to egypt that's where we want
our little passport and then we got to
dig apart like little artifacts and we
got a little sphinx out of ours uh we
went to japan we made sushi it's awesome
it's really cool um it's fun it's easy
and i'm telling you your kids are going
to love it little passports is the
perfect gift for the little adventurers
in your life here are just a few of the
subscriptions you'll find for kids three
to five they have the early explorers
kit that ignites their imagination and
curiosity with hands-on activities games
stories that explore the wonders of the
world from the deep sea to the dinosaurs
for kids five to eight they have the
science junior kit that unearths new
discoveries with activities
investigating everything from how sound
works to how rockets launch and for kids
six to ten that's the world edition kit
explores new cultures one country at a
time which is what we did through
projects puzzles souvenirs and
activities that spark a global
connection this holiday give the young
explorer in your life a world of
adventure get 20 off any new
subscription with promo code honeydew at
littlepassports.com order by december
20th for christmas delivery free
shipping is included that's
littlepassports.com
promo code honeydew now let's get back
to the duke and you're on your period
all these things are going on and it's
my [ __ ] birthday yeah now it's
officially your birthday yeah oh you've
woken up on your birthday there and so
yeah so then i'm like i don't know if
i'm in an apartment or a house at this
point so then i'm like take me the
[ __ ] front door i will i will scream
like bloody murder so he takes the front
door he lets me out
and i like go through my phone my
phone's almost dead at this point but i
have a bunch of texts you walk past
people in the house do you see no
because it's at like 5 30 in the morning
six o'clock in the morning it's very
very early
and i have a bunch of texts for my
birthdays and my phone's almost dead so
i'm like i'm i'm literally in shock so
when people say like
when something when someone goes through
something and they're saying what they
did like oh they found a dead body or
like you know and people like why would
you do that next why would you do that
next when your body is in shock you were
doing nothing logical because i should
have written the house number down i
should have like
marked like taken a picture of the guy
taking a picture of the house like
there's so many things that i should
have done but the first thing is flee
and get to safety that's the first thing
in your mind which it should be
yeah exactly so i call i facetime my the
last person who decks me which is my
friend who lives in [ __ ] wisconsin
which is so stupid i facetime her which
takes up so much battery but again i'm
just not thinking
and she like
answers the face i was like happy
birthday but then sees me and i'm like i
literally look like charlie sarah from
monster my hair's everywhere i'm like
and she's like what the [ __ ] happened to
you and i was like i was just raped and
my phone literally dies it dies
so i'm like okay great i'm in the middle
of [ __ ] compton i don't even know
where you are when you walk outside
listen the tall palm trees let you know
what kind of neighborhood you're in
around here you know
palm trees
yeah
that you know when there's a car parked
in the front lawn of a house you're like
i don't think i'm in bed hills over here
they don't have hoa
clearly there's no homeowners
uh yeah so i i see a shell station down
so i go off and it's still dark at this
point no it's it's light it's early so
it must have been like six six thirty it
was light um and he lived off a side
street that had like
that was on a kind of a main street to
wilshire or one of the biggest streets
but it was like a
so i'm just literally taking off i'm
sprinting i'm like i need to get to the
shell station i need help so i'm like
sprinting to the shell station i'm like
what the [ __ ] just happened like
how am i alive i'm like i'm literally
[ __ ] alive so i go to the shell
station
i i don't have a tampon which i know is
like but i'm bleeding everywhere i get i
get to the shell station
and i'm like can i use a phone charger
and the guy's like no
and i was like okay can i use your phone
and the guy was like no and i was like
okay i need help i was like i was i was
like screaming in this shelter i was
like i was [ __ ] raped i was just
raped i need someone to help me
and
he was like i'm sorry like i can't help
no way yeah so then i
are you serious yeah so i i like throw a
temper tantrum and i'm like [ __ ] you
like you don't even know what it's like
to be a woman
and then i leave and i leave my [ __ ]
phone there on the couch i know and i
have all i have are tampons because i
bought tampons because i needed them and
i i'm like trying to go i walk down the
street i try to go to jack and box it's
closed i try to go to another gas
station they don't have a at this point
i'm like can i borrow a phone they say
no and i don't have my phone but i just
threw a temper tantrum in the shell
station i'm like well i'm not going back
there i'm just gonna get a new phone
pocket like
at this point i'm like abandoning
everything i'm like i need to like talk
to someone i know like i'm losing my
mind
so i get on the bus
hoping it's gonna bring me towards santa
monica i get on the bus and i'm like
excuse me
are we going towards santa monica and
the guy looks at me and he bursts out
laughing he goes santa monica
no
i'm like i don't even know what that
means and then another guy comes to me
is like excuse me excuse me i think he
was going to be like i'll tell you how
to get to santa monica he goes i just
want to let you know you're beautiful
i swear to god you're with the guys but
it's like and i know i sound like i'm
bragging here
but it's always like
it
i wanted to punch him in the face i was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me i was
like i'm clear i have like a twig in my
hair the lunatics you track the loonies
exactly
and so i just get off the bus at the
next stop i'm like okay well i'm going
the wrong way
i see a motel i try to check into the
motel because i'm like
if i can get a room at the motel they
have a phone in there it'll cost me
[ __ ] 45 may call but at least i can
make a call the guy's like we're booked
up i'm like what how is this motel and
[ __ ]
so then i'm like i need can i use your
bathroom like i need to put a tampon in
he's like no so at this point i'm losing
my mind i literally pulled out my pants
in the middle of this [ __ ] motel and
i just put up my tampon no yes
because
yes i'm like i have to i i literally i
need to put the stamp on and no one is
helping me
are they saying anything to you no
because of cour
the people around me they're going to
the bathroom too they're taking a poop
next to me so it was just like it's like
it's la like no one and i i was just so
fed up and i had to solve one problem i
mean i didn't fully pull it out but i
was like you know i'm so sorry my god no
it's fine but no one wants to help you
yeah and i you know
it just made me it gives you a lot of
empathy when you're in this i mean not
that
it sounds like so shitty that it took
that to be like
wow
but
it was [ __ ] yeah i mean i looked like
[ __ ] i looked like i
was strung out like and i kind of was
you know like i just been off to the
dude on the bus
that's true that was the apple of his
eye
okay everyone you know every trash
what's one man's trash yeah [ __ ] that
but um
so i get back on the bus to go the other
way cause i'm like i went the wrong way
and i was like i think i remember
starbucks so i took the bus backwards
until i saw a starbucks and then i got
off
i'm like
starbucks will help me and they did they
had a phone
and the only numbers i know you have to
tell them you were raped no
i walk into starbucks and it's like i
was raped and everyone stops and then
like goes back like a movie no
um i was just like i really need your
phone and the and it was women at the it
was the first time i saw a woman and
they were like oh my god okay yeah i
didn't have to say anything it's just i
could tell i was in trouble which was
nice the compassionate humans yeah
exactly
and uh
so yeah the only phone numbers i know
are my parents or my high school crush
nah you still haven't memorized yeah
you can't call it
hey stephen how's your wife anyway
[Laughter]
um
yeah so
i was like
who do i call you know because i didn't
want to have to call my parents on my
birthday and say that i was
raped like i was just like i don't know
who to call because
but i was like all right i'm gonna call
my dad and
i called my dad and i was just like
um i needed you to call my friend like
to pick me up i was like i was uh mugged
i told my dad i was mugged because it
felt easier
and my dad was like oh my god my dad was
like oh anna like what the
you really need help and i was like i
know that's what i've been trying to say
like i need help like i
i'm i'm [ __ ] like i i don't know what
to do and i've been feeling like
really lost and like this is just
another thing you know
and so my friend came and picked me up
and i died from the night before no my
friend from college so she still doesn't
know this even happened to you no
so
i might she my friend
like saved my life like she came and she
went and we i was like i lost my phone
at this shell station she went back in
and got it for me and the guy had
charged it for me which was nice but i'm
like where the [ __ ] was the charter the
first round but it was nice that he
charged it
and then um
so
i she gets in the car and she's like we
have to go to ucla rape center like we
have to and i was like i don't want to
and why why didn't you want to because i
was just like embarrassed and i felt
um i was in a lot of pain and i had like
i was covered in bruises i was covered
in blood i smelled like horrible i just
i didn't want it to be real
and as soon as
you go to a center like that it's real
and it's documented and
you're reliving it
exactly again and again and again
and then it's there is this thing of
like
whenever
it when after you know like
when
when i got when you get
i don't want to say the general you but
when someone get when i got raped i felt
like
did i get raped like
i did but it's like
was it my fault
it was my fault because i was too drunk
again and i
got into a wrong car because at this
point on the way home i had called ben
and he was like are you i [ __ ] knew
that guy was sketchy i had this he was
like [ __ ] like i shouldn't have [ __ ]
laughed he was like
i i shouldn't like he was blaming
himself which is not fair i was like
this is not your fault did you call
stephen
like stephen where are you this would
have never happened if you just married
me in high school
um yeah so i i just so we go back i was
like can we just go back to the hotel i
just need to lay down for a second like
i just need to like compose myself can
we just say this because we said this
before you and i were talking like
sure did you drink too much like you
said yup and could you have been yeah
but none of that gives anyone else the
freedom or license to rape someone
exactly ever if there's a woman in the
back of your car and your job is to
drive that lady somewhere and her tits
are out and her purse is scattered on
your [ __ ] seat it doesn't give you
the license to do anything to her
and i think what so many people do
and the problem is
is after this [ __ ] happens the woman is
always blamed this is what you were
saying it's like
and look i do have my drinking problem
like
i'm not gonna deny that but but i also
want to shed light on this part here
because
we're going to get into it but this is a
thing i also had a friend of mine um i
was a friend of a friend i've mentioned
this before his wife went out with her
girlfriends had a girls night out and
did the responsible thing took a uber or
cab or something home and then the guy
dropped her off but
then the husband had stayed home he was
just upstairs chilling when she got back
and the cabbie or whatever the driver
waited for her to get to her front door
put the key in the lock and then he
tackled her from behind and attempted to
rape her in her home there but the
husband was home and came down and
[ __ ] the dude up
um and the cops then told them this is a
thing this happens quite a bit you have
no idea how often this happens so you
know try not to get so [ __ ] up and get
in someone's car where you can't
remember [ __ ] because you're easy prey
exactly
and
it so who didn't believe you
well it wasn't that no it wasn't that no
one believed me but it was just that
general this is what they do to yeah
like if you hear a woman if a woman
comes out that she's been raped like a
lot of times people will be like she's
doing this for attention she
she
like was too drunk she was oh yeah but
did you see him
yeah look at her instagram
and it's like
that's just not it's so frustrating
because um
even when i went back to i had to go
with the detectives to go back and
identify the house there was another
call that came in about a girl who woke
up to an uber driver [ __ ] her
and she was like very embarrassed and
she was adamant that she did not want to
go to the rape center she did not want
to report it because she was so scared
her parents were going to find out which
is so sad because i know that people you
would want to find out you would hope
yeah it's like but there's this this
fear of i was really drunk i shouldn't
have been in that they're going to be
mad at me they're going to be mad at me
because i should know better exactly and
that's what's so sad is like yes no one
should be getting obliterated like
for their own sake but
it's shitty that it's like you should
have known better you should have known
that there are so many guys out there
raping and your own mind does that to
you you're saying you started feeling a
little bit of that yeah because i was
sober for like
i i've been trying to get sober and then
before covet i was like seven months
sober and
i ever said well it's not like
anything's bad it's ever happened
nothing bad has ever happened to me and
it's like yes bad stuff has happened to
me but then
what i waited till this
like i couldn't [ __ ] put down the
[ __ ] drink
because i needed it so bad that i almost
died
and
i was just mad at myself because i do
stupid [ __ ] when i drank all the time i
or i did and
i was
it like took it this far
like i always would be like whenever i
went to aaa i'd be like well i've never
had a rock bottom like that it's like
they would always be like yet and then
here i was on my [ __ ] birthday just
sitting in my own filth
and after being
raped by this kid
and i
so we're at the hotel my friend took me
back but she's like we're going to the
rape center and we're in the bed i was
like
i go
can't they just come here
i don't want to go and so she called the
front desk of this nice hotel i was like
hey do you guys have a rape kit
do you guys have a rape kit like it's
right next to the sewing kits
[Music]
and they were like um no and she's like
and then a hotel is there
you call yourself a hotel
i'm writing this in the yelp review no
rich kid it's a hotel for god's sake
yeah so she hangs up and she goes
wow i i don't think i'm processing this
right here
sorry
because we're like we still have that
today i'm like
well i like dexterity hey excuse me do
you have a rape kit
what okay how about the time
yeah yeah
um
yeah so it just it so what happens can
you talk about what it's like to go to
this center yeah i mean the ucla rape
center
i don't want to be like it's lit but
like
i can't say it
i want to i want to say it is such a
helpful resource because hey yeah this
is a better way
you know you have to get
like
that that was the other thing i'm
clearly this is why i need to go to
rehab because i wasn't processing
anything they're like we're gonna give
you a shot of penicillin i'm like do you
have any extra for her
we're going out tonight and um
[Music]
and they're doing you know they have to
take photos so you have to like open
your legs and they have to take photos
of all the bruises and go inside with it
just
horrible
but for what you're saying if i'm
understanding it correctly is for
considering such a horrible experience
they do a good job yeah
exactly they you get free sweatpants
they're haynes designer are they really
yeah what are you doing i know haynes
just haynes yeah they don't say like
rape center
on the butt
victim number on the side like just this
year like holy crap like squid games
775. you get jumpsuits
um no but they give you like
fresh underwear and sweatpants which i
thought they might just say like ucla or
something
they're just like regular okay regular
old gray
hanes uh but
yeah bootleg cut
boot cut
you got joggers
i sell joggers
do you have any ones with pockets
[Laughter]
for my medications
but they give you like you know plan b
and they give you
all these things that you will need like
i had to take a pill for 28 days to
prevent aids because i was like okay
this is what i want to ask you yeah what
tell me all this stuff so they give you
a pill for that in case this guy had
aids yeah so i guess basically they're
like even if he didn't use a condom the
chances of you getting aids are 0.01
is that right that's what they said like
it's very hard it's not uh through
uh
contact yes through seminal fluids and
all that yeah i'm not really sure what
about also like these guys are
aggressive what if they tear and you
bleed well you were already bleeding i
was already bleeding i had a lot of
tearing and i they were like we i mean
the chances of this person having aids
is like pretty small and i was like
i don't know i've had a pretty tough
year i think i'm gonna take the i think
i'm gonna go with the pill
i don't trust the 01 yeah i think i'm in
that as far as bad luck goes
plus i love taking pills so let's just
add it add it to the [ __ ] list
oh
like yeah the percentage is really well
i'm like
no because yeah of course what are the
odds that you get in the wrong car and
someone you know it's like actually
pretty high but
um
i want to talk about that in a minute
too the whole scam of the wrong car
thing but yeah go through so you had to
take a pill for they give you plan b as
well in case you could be pregnant i
mean jesus christ yeah they give you a
shot for gonorrhea um and chlamydia they
give you a shot for that stuff
nothing for herpes though per usual
they're like
that was and that was the other thing my
mom was like
trying to be positive
she was like oh my god
maybe you gave him herpes
maybe ruined his life
like you ruined yours that's your mom
yeah
and i go can you not i was just like
because my mom flew out which was very
nice but we're like driving to [ __ ]
rehab
in arizona we're in the car and she like
that's her big i'm like
can we just listen to the radio like can
we just not
brainstorm ideas how this is great like
but shoot you know my mom is really
supportive and i'm really lucky to have
parents that i can tell and trust and
that were there for me when did you
finally tell them
so i
the truth i mean oh um about an hour
later you did i called my mom i mean
that would just destroy me yeah it was
tough it was tough it was it's it's
tough to tell your parents like
you know were did they
do anything you feared like you should
have known better or were they very
no they didn't they they were really
understanding and they
um
i mean they knew i'd been going through
a really hard time so it was like
and i've never been great with drinking
so like
but at this point it's like they were
just like you need help you know you but
what you were saying yeah you reached
out for it exactly and like
who who did you tell that day about the
darkness and all that did you
end up talking to them again because you
thought you were gonna die but look what
happened to you my friend who picked me
up from that was her yeah and i like
again she like saved my life like forced
me to go to the rape center and was like
you have to do this like and if she
wasn't there i wouldn't have gone okay
so this was when december uh no this was
may may of this year
[ __ ] this is only a few months back yeah
but then honestly when you go to rehab
like six months
yeah i went to rehab for a month which
felt like a year and time is frozen and
i learned so much about myself and my
drinking problem and like
also
it helped me process it so much because
i was around so many the rehab i went to
was for mental illness and ptsd and
trauma so it wasn't just like addiction
which
addiction comes a lot of addiction comes
from trauma and
you know mental illness and i have all
that so
it's
it was very helpful for me because i was
around people who have been
you know i i had a very terrible
situation but then you meet i met so
many people who had been raped since
they were a child you know god and it's
like it gives you such perspective and
i'm like i'm so [ __ ] lucky like i i
am so lucky at the end of the day like
and that's why i'm able to not drink is
because
i mean
six months isn't a long time but
i know like i've always been like oh
whenever i stop drinking i'd be like
i'll probably drink again like whatever
but this is like
i
just
i'm so privileged and i'm so lucky as a
human and my life is so great that like
i was really killing myself and i was i
was taking full advantage of that
privilege and thinking nothing would
ever happen to me
and
it it did and it it saved my life and he
knocked me out i he did how do you okay
that there's so many questions can i
just say this out loud so i don't forget
i want to know what's going on with him
right now cause i asked you if he's in
jail or prison you said no i want to
talk about the back up on these rape
kits i want to talk about the
um
the switcheroo with the uber and [ __ ]
yeah what you also just said so i think
he knocked me out because i had two hand
bruises like holding me like
it would be like he was holding me like
this and i had two very distinct bruises
and my head hurt so bad and i had like a
small bump but i did not get a cat scan
because i spent
literally five six hours in the rape
center waiting and i was just like i
need to go home like if i have a
concussion like
i i don't know but like i just need to
go to bed like i just didn't want to go
wait and then get my head scanned so i
guess i can't say for sure
but it's weird that i had like a bump on
the back of my head and then my so i
feel like
i also had outgoing calls to 911.
you did and my ex and my ex-boyfriend
from college who never called me back uh
never come back no but he has a new
girlfriend and like i don't think he
knows this severe i don't know
he has a girlfriend so it's like i
called him at one in the morning
like
what he what he didn't think i was like
escaping like he didn't know the
situation so i don't blame him at all
but but you did try to call 9-1-1 i did
why couldn't they ping you and figure
out where you were i but all the calls i
realized were like cancelled or like
halfway they didn't go through all the
way so i think maybe i was trying to
call and he like he was stopping
stopping it and then knocked me out but
i tried to call an uber from a parking
lot in culver city at that point so i
think i tried to get away and um
and that's it put me in this random and
i looked it up and it was a parking lot
so i was in this random location in
culver city so that's why i think he
wrote me in a parking lot because i'm
like why was i there
and why were my outgoing calls like
cancelled at exactly
the first 10 minutes of
the hour which is crazy like it's just
so insane that
this
that's why when i woke up and i was like
i told my friend and who was with me the
night i thought i was gonna die and like
was there all day with me i was like i
think i have a problem she was like i've
known you for 10 years and like
i feel
yeah like you do and it was like this
weird moment of like
[ __ ]
like [ __ ] i have to be honest with
myself
so tell me about this dude where is he
now
probably graduation
oh my god taking his sats
so he's not in jail he's not in prison
no because tell me about this system of
the [ __ ] rape kit [ __ ] so i didn't
write down the address of the house but
i remembered it was between two houses
and then the first house i thought i was
like it's either this house or this
house because they look very similar but
they were two streets away but on the
same side in the same
and then they were like we see your
phone at this one i was like okay that's
probably it and he's like was it this
car and he sent the detective sent me
a name of a car and i looked it up and
it was a white kia
and i was like this looks right and then
the slogan of the kia was reliably fun
and i was like ah maybe this isn't it
you know
i don't know
maybe not
either the kia people are liars or
this is the wrong car because i i don't
think i had such a good time there
nothing um
but
so
basically the police were like
we want to wait until your dna comes
back and we need to run it through the
system because a lot of times girls will
go to the rape center to get the plan b
the aids medication the penicillin all
this stuff and
but then when it goes to trial they're
like i can't do this i i i don't want to
face him i don't want it to be public i
don't want this to be a public record
like they're just ashamed and
but the dna will still be in the rape
center and the institute it's in the
system yeah if it happens again exactly
that person's identified exactly so and
by the way 18 i mean
you've either saved a lot of women from
hopefully not having this happen again
or i wonder how many times he's done
this already yeah so
i know that they have dna they got dna
that was the la and i texted the
detective yesterday after i was like
booked this i was like we need to
i should text the detective see what's
up and he was like we still no dna match
results yet and i'm like can you just he
said they don't want to go knocking on
the doors to the house because because
he could go run
and i'm like well at this point you'll
know who the [ __ ] it is exactly for sure
exactly he's 18.
yeah
so
i don't know i mean they're dragging
their feet but it's yeah rape kits are
backed up three months god
and these rapists literally walk in the
streets for three months before some of
them get picked up yeah
well also because the lapd funding got
cut so people are like oh we did it you
know we did the thing
we cut funding they don't cut the teslas
the guns that [ __ ] does not get cut it's
overtime
and rape kits so that's what's being
held up and the detectives who worked
with me were very kind and they were
like look we can't work overtime on this
case legally we cannot work overtime
because they have cut our funding we
cannot work overtime
so
that's what got caught
and
as a result it's like i you know i can't
do anything about this and i i wasn't
talking about it really that much but at
this point i'm like
you know someone needs to [ __ ] help
because i i don't know what to do and i
what am i going to do show up to the
guy's house and
you know [ __ ] charlie's there in his
ass and
literally i but
i
you know all i can do is like
trust the system and hope that they get
a dna match but what if this is his
first time there would never be a dna
match exactly then he said then what
happened then he said he'd knock on
doors he's like we just want to cover
all grounds
all our grounds before we start knocking
on doors and i'm like
i think it's just a [ __ ] to get like a
warrant
so
i don't know i really don't and like
you've done your own detective work
it's like so
no
because i'm like i need to work on like
my therapy from it as opposed to like
trying to get obsessed with it
and
um
i was like very into being like where's
where are we at now but by august i was
just like if i put my energy into this
i'm going to get so frustrated and i
just spent a month in
working on myself and going through deep
therapy that i don't need to go
backwards by
because what can i do i can't it's not
like i can put him in jail
and so
as much as i would like him off the
streets so he's not raping other women
there's nothing i can really do
unfortunately
but tell other women to [ __ ] check
the
license plate okay so share this about
the whole
um thing the police taught you that this
is a thing that guys or these people are
doing where they
the whole ride canceled to explain that
please so the police officers were like
well there's a good they wanted my
original driver who it says canceled and
i was like why he canceled it wasn't it
wasn't this guy and they were like
because what a lot of times uber drivers
are doing is if they have the same car
like a toyota corolla white
they'll pull up to a crowded bar like
[ __ ] 12 12 and i see them outside at
lax all of them they there's so many of
them that look like priuses whatever
exactly and then they'll see a drunk
girl they'll know she's drunk they'll
cancel it
and then
they'll they'll pull up right behind
each other so then you get into the
other car and they cancel
and uh or the roll down there and i
don't know if he rolled down his window
and said hannah i can't really remember
that so i don't want to say and i don't
know if this is what happened he might
have just been a random kid who heard
that you can do this just roll up to a
club and pick up a girl and so i don't
know if the other driver was involved
but this is a thing that's happening we
all know the struggle finding a gift for
your special person that's practical and
unique well look no further we
absolutely love enzo rings they're
stylish silicone rings the perfect gift
for anyone active or who works with
their hands a lot look here's one right
here i'm telling you it's more flexible
than i thought way more durable it's
strong
kirsten's husband wears one i know a lot
of guys back home that work with their
hands my buddy shannon in the junkyard
wears them enzo rings make a great
wedding band replacement they're so much
safer more comfortable than a
traditional metal ring plus enzo rings
offers a wide variety of styles so you
can find your perfect match their
elements collection is infused with real
precious materials like diamond rose
gold platinum and more and their
handcrafted collections mixed by hand so
you can give a one-of-a-kind gift all
right trust us order enzo rings today to
get ahead of holiday shipping check out
enzo rings elements collection and other
best sellers at our special url
enzorings.com honeydew and for a limited
time you're going to get 10 off your
first purchase of any collection when
you use the promo code honeydew don't
miss out for 10 off that's promo code
honeydew at ensorings.com
honeydew flu season is in full swing
proper hydration and vitamins can help
support a strong immune system are you
going to be enjoying a few extra drinks
now the holidays are approaching you
probably are so this is what you need
liquid iv hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone i take it
every day every day i take liquid iv
tangerine's my favorite they just sent
me another one now for a sleep aid that
i'm going to start taking i will tell
you how that goes because i like to
sleep
watermelon's another good one and i'm
telling you they've got right now
especially with the vitamin c and
everything in these they contain five
essential vitamins more vitamin c than
an orange and as much potassium as a
banana they're healthier than sugary
sports drinks there's no artificial
flavors or preservatives and there's
less sugar than an apple it's made with
clean ingredients non-gmo vegan and free
of gluten dairy and soy we keep them
here at the studio for our guests all
right so grab your favorite liquid iv
flavors nationwide at walmart or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquid iv.com
and use code honeydew at checkout that's
25 off of anything you order when you
get better hydration today using the
promo code honeydew at liquidive.com
by now you've probably seen about a
thousand gift guides for the holiday
season gifts for moms gifts for guys
gifts for your neighbor's cousin's dog
you could study all those gift guides
and shop at 10 different places or you
could start your shopping at raycon and
get a gift everyone will use raycon
wireless earbuds you guys know i love my
raycons i travel with them i exercise
with them i wear them when i walk my
stepson stole the other pair so i had to
get two right i love them raycons give
you an amazing audio quality wherever
you go whether you use them to pump up
wind down to work or work out with their
latest model you get three new sound
profiles to make sure everything you're
listening to sounds its best with just
the right amount of bass pure mode is
podcast listening where you should be
listening to the honeydew here blues
instrumental they've got a balance mode
that's rock heavy rock and metal and a
bass mode with hip hop edm and reggae
raycons are available in five stylish
colors so you can pick a perfect one for
everyone on your list with free shipping
and returns gifting is easier than ever
the holidays are coming up faster than
you think and now is the time to knock
out that gift list and avoid the last
minute shipping scramble especially
because right now my listeners are going
to get 15 off site wide with code
holiday at
buyraicon.com honeydew all right again
go to
byracon.com honeydew and use the code
holiday because it's the holidays y'all
today to get 15 off your entire raycon
order buy raycon.com
slash honeydew now let's get back to the
do so when i
when i
you know the day it happened my friend
my other friend texted i was texting her
about it
and she was like i'm gonna connect you
with my friend who this happened to like
six months ago
so i talked to this already you're
meeting people that have had this
already yeah exactly and i get another
text my friend oh this happened to my
friend my mom
said that her friend's daughter who they
didn't tell anyone because it was like
the daughter was embarrassed like it
happened to her and
so the girl that um my friend connected
me to she said the same thing well the
same thing happened to her outside of
delilah in hollywood
but she said she had
two and a half drinks
and
she had flown from new york and it was
like 2 a.m so she like fell asleep
against the window
and she woke up to the she woke up to
the guy having sex with her
and she
punched him in the face good he grabbed
her phone and he tried to steal her
watch and she it was like a cartier
rolex or one of those watches and she
like punched the [ __ ] out of him and ran
to a house and got help
but then she
did the kit she went to trial that guy
his dna was linked to like five rape
victims in chicago [ __ ] and maybe like
two more in la so he had gone from
chicago to la
and um
his face so they put his face on the
news and then more girls came forward so
his dna was linked and then the fa his
face on the news more girls came forward
so i can't yeah it was like something
anyway so she was like it's so good you
report it because this is happening like
every single day so there's a chance
just let's talk statistically here this
kid has no [ __ ]
dna in the system and now he does
so if he never rapes again
he could get away with this one
if he does
three years from now
you
could then
see his face or whatever it is when they
get this guy i'm like oh my god that's
the [ __ ] guy yeah but outside of that
there's a chance he could get away with
this yeah
that's so [ __ ] up it's so
[ __ ] up and it's almost like you get
one free rape if you're a man
yeah that's how it feels [ __ ] insane
that's what it sounds like the system
says to a woman they get one free one uh
hopefully hopefully he does it again and
then we can help you
yeah holy [ __ ]
exactly and the guy was like well you
know
even if we even with all the dna and
when we go to trial there's a lot of he
said she said
no no with dna how the [ __ ] is it he
said what you mean this guy could say
you were it was consensual yeah
but i'm like also
i mean i was with a friend
who my friend
i have a witness who he dropped off and
was like there's no
way
and also my bruises and
just
there's no tearing your injuries exactly
i mean also your second day of your
period that's not that
common for people to want to just
[ __ ] in a parking lot like that yeah
yeah exactly there's a lot of things on
your side here yeah and it's just like
i
when he said that i
i know he said that because he had to
and it's true it is he said she said but
i was like
it
sent a chill down my i was like he said
she said
i was raped literally like and not even
and that's the thing is like there's a
difference between like my friend goes
wow you were like rape raped
and i was like yeah because it's like
there's the rape in college where you're
like no no but he's like in a frat and
like his dad has a boat so it's like
fine but then there's like
get [ __ ] picked up knocked out
and [ __ ] raped and to be taken back
to his home like why
what do you think that's about you think
he really thought he could pull off this
was consensual and you got [ __ ] up
yeah i think instead of just leaving you
out on the side of the road somewhere or
drop you off somewhere that's why i
think he was young because i think you
know it's like they say that peop kids
who like kill little animals they'll
grow up and kill people it's like a
sickness that grows and is progressive
and i think he was young and was like i
don't want to kill this person but i
can't you know who knows if he gets off
like what's he going to be in five years
yeah
and and what how many other victims in
that five years exactly and it's just
like all
i can say is
and the thing is i can say like
be careful but
i was a drunk [ __ ] like i get it it's
like
you think like oh i'm getting into this
we have been conditioned to be like oh
i'm getting into someone's car it's fine
it's on a nap
but like
when you're drunk it's just
there's
you don't think to check the license
plate you know and like even before i do
i always check make and model and
license plate well now i do and i say
who are you here for yeah and if they
don't say hannah i mean that now they do
but i
okay well not everyone's you okay
but even but also i'm not in your
defense i'm not shit-faced when i'm
doing it i'm not a drinker so
yeah yeah and but even when i would go
to work in new york like on a rainy day
there would be so many cars lined up i
would always get in the wrong [ __ ]
car i'm a space cadet like i just i'm
it's not uncommon to get in the wrong
car exactly it's not i've i've known
people i've watched it happen to me in
line like oop wrong one yeah pop right
out yeah exactly josh potter did it
right out here in front of the studio
one day he goes i got in a stranger's
car i go you thought it was your videos
i did yeah
guys what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
yeah and it's and so
um and now that there's
and they're now predators who know that
you know and they're taking advantage so
i can't totally put it on uber but i
will say that uber has not done anything
to prevent stuff like this happening
they don't have
a lot of security they know they know
that this is happening they're obviously
aware but they're not going to promote
it or they're not going to be like we're
fixing this because
then people are going to make aware of
the problem and no one's going to want
to use uber yeah exactly
and
um it's that's why i love that you're
making people aware of this because it
is a thing it's a thing it's a big thing
and what's sad is it like for women
it's not like i'm sure there are dudes
out there robbing dudes or whatever but
i'm pretty sure there aren't female uber
drivers raping men
uh when they pass out in the back of the
car
no yeah no yeah
and
i
it's
it's where are you now mentally with
everything i mean
how's how's the rehab going and
i mean it's
god you're going through rehab off of
this like this is i don't
i'm not making a joke here but i would
understand someone wanting a drink after
an experience like this right yeah i
know the day after i was like
or that day when we got back my friend i
was like you're raped on your birthday
literally
i mean it's like i'm so sorry
that's like a name of a
memoir raped on my birthday
birthday rape so what do you what are
you hoping for now are you trying to get
to a place of just being clean and sober
moving forward yeah and i think just um
i've just had a lot more patience with
myself and like
um
everything used to be such a big deal
like i wanted to have a late night by
the time i was 30. i needed to be passed
at this club before i was 30. i needed
my own tv show i need to be sad like i
needed to get this audition like
everything was like my career my career
like i need to be here i need to be here
and then i was like going to la then
going to hawaii and i got [ __ ] raped
and i ended up in rehab like and i in
rehab you can't like
you can't do anything you don't have
access i got access to my phone like 30
minutes a day
but
my life was literally on hold and i was
like i needed this i really needed this
i needed to be here and
just focus on myself and figure out
my dad said that to me he was like
you know you've lived your 20s and good
and bad things have happened how do you
want your 30s to look and while you're
in there just think of who you want to
be
and like
what kind of person you want to be and
what you want out of this life and then
in the next 10 years
and
that really helped me because i was like
yeah i want to be successful but i also
want to have a family like i want to be
a functioning human who's well-rounded
as opposed to like
i need this by this time and and having
these times so much pressure on
ourselves for nothing for literally
nothing nothing and i'm like i could
have been dead like i should be [ __ ]
dead the fact that he didn't throw my
body into the la river well could have
been thrown into the river yet yeah and
it's like when you when i had such a
[ __ ] like i should be dead
i'm like yeah i'm gonna go
on a trip like i'm going to
like
i'm going to colombia i'm going with a
friend which i'm like
people are like whoa after you got raped
you're going to go to colombia that's
what people have been saying to me i'm
like
even after you got raped you're going to
go to colombia i'm like why are you
saying this to me anyway but i'm also
just like
i
or i'd be like oh this guy doesn't like
me or like i cared so much about dating
and now i'm like
i don't need
i got a dog
i'm like
i'm not drinking
if i don't want to do something like
i'll have a commercial audition that i
don't want to do but before i was like
oh i have to do this i'm like i don't
want to do it i'm not doing it sorry i'm
tired
and i put priorities like i'm seeing you
know i've spent a lot of time with my
parents and my brother and like
people that
my closest friends have really been
there for me and shown up in ways that
i'm like so lucky
um
that
it's
i don't want to say like
it
it's like so
this is like the comic i mean it just
goes so dark that i'm like you know like
that sex was life-changing like it but
like
yeah i i know it's like so [ __ ] up but
like that's i understand how your mind
works yeah it just did change my life
and like a part of me feels grateful he
knocked me out and i don't remember it
because like then i would probably never
be able to be intimate again
so i think you really think so i think
so yeah if i had
if i had remembered i think it would
have been very it would be impossible
yeah
um and it's already hard for me to like
trust people and whatever but
i think having that physical
you know and i watch people in rehab
dissociate which is where you like
completely
it's like your brain
loses control of where it is and it goes
to a different place and time it's so
crazy to see someone dissociate
and i'm so lucky that isn't happening to
me um
and
like for everything that happened i'm i
walked away i thought so i thought i
lost my
license
at his house and i was like what if he's
wow in a gang what if he's
you know anything anything whoever after
you exactly
and
i was like my parent i it has my parents
address on it
so i i felt so guilty i was like i
really hope that
i i didn't like
put them in danger or something and then
i went to rehab
and they go through all your stuff and
they organize my backpack
and my license was at the top and i was
like this is a sign from [ __ ] god
like thank you
and
it it truly and like i was in this
sexual assault um lawsuit with usc
huh with the gynecologist
oh yeah so you're a part of that yeah no
yeah
hannah yeah did you talk about that last
time i don't know i think so
but i know of the yeah that's what it
was you talked about it on stage at the
comedy store saturday night yeah so
there's a gynecologist who was what
molesting women for years molesting
women for years and the first time i got
a pabst or i said i didn't want a pap
smear and he like made me have one and
like did all this weird [ __ ] i told all
my friends and they're like just forgot
about it he's probably a weirdo and i
just never went back to him and then i
found out he he was doing criminal
activity so i i wasn't even gonna sue at
first
but i tried to report to the school and
they're like there's nothing we can
really do for you and i was like then
why am i reporting this you asked for
victims to come forward and now you're
not doing anything for us because they
were like we can give you therapy at usc
and i was like i live in new york
they're like well we can't pay for
therapy in new york and i was like okay
[ __ ] this it might they can't do
anything either yeah so then my friend i
get it you're seeing all these doors
slam every opportunity including can i
just use your toilet i've been raped now
yeah no can i charge my phone nah
exactly but this was like so this was
leading up to it i was in a lot it was
in the la so then i joined gloria
allred's like that whole thing and
during this time i'm writing a essay on
how
getting assaulted at usc has affected my
life and then this [ __ ] happens and i'm
like my lawyer and i are finishing this
letter in rehab so i'm like telling him
on the phone i'm like on this [ __ ]
rehab communal phone like
uh yeah comma uh so
i'm currently in rehab like it's just
like i'm finishing this letter to a
lawyer to explain what my settlement
should be and why this has [ __ ] up my
life as i'm as
and then i get out of rehab and find out
how much money i'm getting and i was
like
like it just felt like everything was
like meant to be
like i just feel
like
you know not
that everything's perfect but
vindicated a little bit yeah like what's
the right word for how you feel now like
what are you how are you feeling right
now i mean the fact that this guy's
still on the streets like being back in
la i thought i've been back a couple
times for a little bit that's right were
you scared to come back is there any of
that it's like scary because i have to
take lifts i take lyft now
which is like i don't know if it's
better but i just can't
like the way uber responded and like
their whole philosophy of hiring people
and how they detach themselves they make
them contractors so they don't have to
deal with this [ __ ]
and it's just so gross to me that i was
like i can't even like deal with uber um
but i do now get into lift every time i
call and i'm just like in la it just i
feel so close to it like i'm like is
this guy a driver like is he on the road
is he gonna pick me up
like man and yeah i i feel so bad you
have to get in these cars again to live
i know it's it's sc it and it's been
hard but um
it's been harder than i thought but
again it's like being sober does help
because i'm like
i and i think if i was drinking i'd be
drinking to the to the blackout point
because i
but now i've just had to
process it and deal with it which is
like again i'm so thankful for that i
and i'm thankful like
my parents paid for rehab which is like
i
is so
like i know how that sounds and
but i'm so like privileged that i got to
do that and i'm like so thankful and
i
am now looking at my life like that like
yes i'm upset that this guy is on the
streets and but like
i'm grateful you're alive i'm grateful
i'm alive and i'm grateful for your
attitude that's everything yeah
gratitude it's like when you look at
things
i never before this looked at things of
what i had i always looked at things of
what i didn't have and i still do that i
still catch myself being like i want
like this
you know like i'll see someone get a
late night and i'm like what the [ __ ]
but
i'm able to be like
that is so unimportant it's so
unimportant it's like
we were talking before i'm you said
you're a comedy store regular right nope
i've been at the comedy store since 1999
and
i'm just in the
system now i'll be hopefully if it
happens next year or the year after i'll
be 50.
i wonder what the oldest person is to
ever get passed i'm curious uh yeah i
mean maybe you that's a record you know
no not but all of it happens if it
happens when it's supposed to happen and
that's the hardest thing to [ __ ]
learn because also when you're
especially in this business you're
hungry and you want to get that and that
and that and that and it's not that
you're greedy or anything it's like all
right we got that what's next exactly if
without a next there's nothing else and
you've got to keep going and going so
the hustle and the ego and all of that
you know you're talking to the right
person about that [ __ ] i get that our
game it's yeah exactly but this year off
year and a half
of no stand up through a pandemic if
that didn't put
into perspective like
you don't need this
and it's not important for life
no it is if that's your money
sure if it's your revenue stream your
job it is but in the end you're here
you're alive
i mean thank god you don't have aids or
anything else from this [ __ ] animal
yeah like i hope they find that
[ __ ] me too i mean that's like
will you be brave enough to go to court
and stuff if they get them and go and
have to face them if you do oh yeah i
i like your she said part of the [ __ ]
exact port yeah i would wan i do want to
go and like
you know i've heard horror stories about
people who
i i know it's going to be harder than
i'm like
imagining it because i'm like i want to
[ __ ] look this guy in the eye and be
like you've cause he
the fact that the next day he was so
confused that i was like you raped me
and in his mind he was like no i didn't
like he had somehow
like justified in his head that what he
did was not incorrect right and me
calling him out he was like
why you know like
he looks scared and i'm like
this [ __ ] this is
but it's also he he was clearly taught
this by someone oh go wait outside 1212
santa monica or go wait outside the
bungalow go it's outside delilah we're
all like there are young girls who get
drunk there all the time wasted falling
down coming out yeah i've seen it you
see it when you drive by up the sunset
strip like oh man exactly i i mean and
the fact that i survived
honestly
one of my friends goes aren't you a
little old to get raped i was like oh my
god
who said that
one of my best friends but she was like
she was like you just hear it like in
college in like early 20s but 29 i was
like yeah i got it
all of you know i recently had botox
okay
i lost some weights uh
i'm looking pretty good right now
but
uh
was it i
i guess the point is like yeah these
guys he was taught this so
the point that a lot of people don't
want to obviously i understand women do
not want to publicize it whatever but um
it
should be known that and i
it sucks because i'm like i was with a
guy friend so you think like stick with
a friend
all the safety drop him off last yeah
exactly well not now definitely or leave
always be with someone or just go back
to his place and then let take another
one from there with him whatever exactly
and that's what should have been done
but
[ __ ] i'm so sorry listen i i want to say
this though i do really appreciate you
coming on and talking about probably the
worst thing it's ever happened to in
your life and bringing awareness because
look it is i'm telling all of you out
there check your plates check the make
and model ask who they're there for look
at the person's face all of that [ __ ]
i had a guy tell the joke about i had a
guy and we were coming back from uh all
things comedy festival in there at
phoenix a few years ago and supposed to
be like a white dude in an suv and this
um latino dude pulled up with a uh
pickup truck didn't match anything he's
like get in i'm like no bro i'm not
[ __ ] getting in like you're gonna
you're gonna bury me in the desert you
know that's always what i think anyway
yeah but yeah check your [ __ ]
that's so scary that's the thing it's
like the and a lot of times they don't
look like their photo
i'm like is this you right it's like
and i had an uber this was years ago but
i this was when uber this was like 2016.
i was in sacramento for i was doing a
featuring at whatever that club is in
sacramento and
uh no it's the worst club than that
i know which one to talk about by the
train track exactly exactly
train track club that was me
um
and i got picked up by this guy and we i
asked him to draw me off at the grocery
store because i was going to go back to
the apartment they were setting me up in
and he was like oh i'll just drive you
back and this is early and he seemed
like a nice guy and i was like okay and
he turned the uber thing off
and i was like oh my god this is like
at least not
it's not charging me but like i then
start to get nervous he goes oh are you
a crazy girl
are you crazy and it's like you do
cocaine and i was like no i was like i
guess i i take an adderall every now and
then and he goes oh you're crazy and
then he pulls out a gun [ __ ] and goes
because i know how to handle crazy girls
and i go oh my god i'm so sorry i no
that's not what he's like just kidding
and then puts it back under her seat
and i
he drops me off at home my friend's
boyfriend had to come to my condo and
like literally i made him i pushed the
couch against the door and made him
sleep on the couch
and um
so and i called uber
yeah i called uber help and she was like
well was he kidding
why he's got a gun in my face who gives
a [ __ ] yeah and it was like i was in the
back seat and he cut but it was like
such a weird experience that i and i
never really reported or never did
anything because i was like who do you
tell like and they didn't really do
anything because they didn't really know
what to do
and i was like okay and
and so [ __ ] like that that like
i mean i was fine and he dropped me off
and like mate you know he's a driver so
i assume that a lot of drivers do have
guns like not i mean depends where you
are but like you don't need to just show
it off and [ __ ] exactly so it's like i
was like i guess maybe he was just like
trying to be funny because he knew i
told him he kept picking me up from the
comedy club but it wasn't funny and it
wasn't a good joke and it wasn't i'm not
justifying it but i didn't report it
because i was like who do i report you
did try to and then lady said was he
kidding yeah that's the end of that
report exactly i might okay
but it's like [ __ ] like this is it's
happening all the time and i think
i don't know it just makes me really sad
that they're
you know it's happening every night to a
girl every night
yeah more than one yeah and it's not
it's not getting a call while you're
going back to try to identify your
rapists exactly christ
and the amount of women this has
happened it's n and it's not just la
it's miami is a big spot chicago's a big
sure new york probably is yeah yeah i
mean i think to
i'm sure new york is a spot too but a
big spot but for some reason new york
feel because not everyone has a car so
it just feels so accessible in something
like la or miami because everyone has a
car so it's like what are you gonna do
tonight well i'm gonna get my car and
i'm gonna go rape a girl because it's
that easy i see
yeah
and
god
it's just terrifying and it's it's
terrifying because
i
like yes i was a big drinker and like
yes i had my i was sloppy whatever but
like
i was
i know girls like me and like
there are a lot of girls like me and i'm
not saying it's they all need to get
sober whatever everyone lives their own
life but like
it
it's just so easy to happen you don't
think it's gonna happen to you and like
i do have so much privilege and i'm so
lucky
but like that does not that
does not stop like the worst things
i was like grew up shel you know grew up
in a cul-de-sac like i did grow up like
very safe and like
you think nothing's ever gonna happen to
you and then it does and it just like
it's terrifying and it's just so it can
happens it all happens so fast and the
fact that i'm still alive is like again
i keep
i just like i'll see [ __ ] on the news
like
that gabby petito story the girl that
went missing and then i read this
article like the 15 most interesting
people that went missing or the 10 most
interesting people of course i clicked
on that because i'm sick
and seven of those 10 people were girls
that looked like me
you know and it's like the natalie hall
i'm basically it's like now
natalie hallway and i'm so lucky that he
didn't just throw me in a dumpster you
are i'm
i think about that oh that's what gives
me panic attacks and also not to have
one right now not to make it worse for
you but
you don't remember being raped so you
wouldn't remember being killed that's
just lights out at that point in that
parking lot and you just never wake up
you don't wake up in that house you
don't have this conversation you don't
talk to your parents i mean that's
that's what's crazy is like when i woke
up my body was like
like it was like fighting still
and i was like
and that's this feeling of like
i need to be doing more with my life and
i need to be helping more people and
like granted i'm i've been mostly in
therapy and not like
you know you make all these 29.
yeah you're a baby you got a long way to
go yet
and i'm glad you want to help i'm glad
you want to help people with it you know
yeah i just think that like
it's just
i it's just so
i
it's so it was like such a terrible
experience and
so almost unbelievable and the fact that
it's happening every single night is
what like breaks my like it sounds so
cliche cheesy to be like breaks my heart
but it really like makes me sick it's it
and
the fact that girls feel like they can't
tell anyone or they don't and that's
makes me so sad because if i hadn't gone
to rehab i would still be drinking
much heavier i would be
i would be a
mess because i wouldn't have processed
it and i would have swallowed it and
like
one thing i learned in rehab too is
there's this book called the body takes
the score
and it's about how trauma lives in the
body and not the
mind
so i had a traumatic massage where this
woman was giving me a massage and she
was like
knew nothing about me she just was a
masseuse at this place but this woman
told me she was kind of a medium and so
she was pushing she was like did you get
into a relationship too fast recently
that went too fast and got uh
like that went bad quickly and i was
like yes and she's like oh i can feel
that under your foot
and then like i had been you know
assaulted before and she was rubbing the
back of my thigh and she was like were
you have you been assaulted before i was
like how do you know this she's like
different points in your body have
different pressures
so even if you think like oh i processed
this oh i i'm okay with it inside your
body
you might not have so like when people
have a certain pain they think oh it's
because i've been working out or oh i've
been doing this but it could be
something psychological wow
so that was
i think the most interesting thing to
take because i would be like
that was my whole life i'm fine i'm fine
it doesn't matter i'll be okay but
truthfully that's not that's impossible
because my body is yeah you're taking so
many bullets until you can't anymore
exactly you're at your limit
exactly
so
it was um
you know i still feel like i'm coming it
was six months ago
but
i do feel like i've come a long ways
like
i
i mean for you to openly
just i walked up to you hugged you and
said hello and you just let it out i
mean at the belly room
on that little landing up there i mean
you've definitely come a ways to at
least talk to me about it i hadn't even
seen you yeah
i guess it's just weird because people
have been like how's your year been and
i'm like
uh
not great you know like been better
and
it's it is my life it's been like
all-consuming but
again i do have this outlook that i
don't think i would
i
because i was the type of drinker i
could have drank for the rest of my life
i could like it's reckless but it's like
a drunk
sloppy girl like
and i needed something like this to
[ __ ] shake me awake
and be like what the [ __ ] are you doing
[ __ ] you're wasting so much of your
life and you're
i'm just i was just pissing away
everything i was given and i have been
given so much in this life and the fact
that i almost lost it at [ __ ]
literally at 29 years is like
such a shame
and i looked i used to say that about i
mean not that i'm like comparing myself
to amy winehouse the genius talent
of wasted potential but like i always
said oh she wasted her potential like
she had so much and then i think of
myself like i'm wasting my potential and
yeah i'm not doing heroin but i might as
well be i'm almost was [ __ ] dead
and
that's the thing about going to rehab
two people be like oh they went to rehab
for this reason they're not that bad
people be like oh well they went to
rehab because you know they have a real
problem and it's like i hate that [ __ ]
because i'm like everyone has a [ __ ]
problem yeah and and how it affects them
doesn't uh matter to you it could
alcohol could affect someone at a level
two but you would a level 10. exactly
and to flip with weed or
coke or something like that i can do it
once a year not be someone's like i'm
doing it nightly exactly
and it's in there is such a stigma to go
into rehab too which i found out and
um
i've always felt that i never want to be
an alcoholic because that just feels
like i lost
i can't control and i'm such a control
freak i'm a perfectionist so i'm like
i want to be able to control
how much i drink but my brain does not
work that way so the only control i can
have is by not drinking at all
which sucks because like
you know i was in a sorority i like love
to party
but
i love you
the party's over
you know uh chelsea skidborn steven
randolph uh-huh they've been telling me
to go to rehab since i was like 24
they're like go to rehab but i called
them a rehab and stephen's in the
background i love him he's like party's
over hannah party's over
shut it down
i was like thank you stephen
uh listen i know this was very uh
difficult and uncomfortable to share um
but thank you for coming on and doing
that i really do love you to death i'm
i'm i love you too i have a great
connection with you and i'm so sorry to
walk up and hear that and then it just
kept getting worse and
and here you are now sharing it so thank
you for real no thanks for i mean i hope
this helps you know definitely going to
help people it will definitely help
people and i i hate to say
but my guess is probably going to be
that we're going to see a few women
in the comments who might be brave
enough to say that this has probably
happened to them yeah that's going to
suck too
so thank you for for bringing light to
this because
again as a guy i'm just worried i'm
gonna get robbed or killed i'm never
worried they're gonna rape me my god so
thank you
you're really strong
thanks um will you please promote
whatever you'd like again um yeah i'm
promoting lyft
i'm promoting yellow taxis
rape whistles and that's my merch it's
rape whistles and [ __ ] val trucks
um
no yeah your podcast my podcast yeah i
talk i guess i've been talking a lot
about what happened
and
it's different life when you're not
drinking but you don't drink i drink but
i'm not a drinker you know i can drink a
half a beer and leave it at the table
and be like i don't want that
so lucky yeah
i don't know if it's lucky but
i guess it is it's kind of lucky i don't
know i talk to people on this show and
they're like
if i have one i'm having 20 and i go i
understand i get i get it now because
i've talked to so many people who say my
body doesn't shut that i don't have a
stop or a
an off switch for alcohol or some people
are food you know yeah so
i get it but thank you for coming on no
thanks for having me i really do
appreciate it um and as always ryan
sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
week stay safe out there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you